how did you guys meet
so
circa around 2017 2016 i was working on
this startup i just left
the uh the financial industry i was with
uh merrill lynch for a few years
and um i met my former one of my former
business partners
uh and we were working on this project
essentially
it was a dow it was it was a lot like a
dow in the metaverse but it was in 2017.
nobody even knew what metaverse was back
then
so um
raising funds in traditional capital was
was hard enough to get it off the ground
and i remember we were out at this
convention actually in tampa
and we bumped into each other
what was it it was like
right outside it was right outside they
had like the lamborghinis outside yeah
this was at the emirates arena um what
was it called synapse summit synapse
yeah it was at synapse in 20 2018 28
2018 set up summit tampa florida and he
was working for a guy are you like 16
years old i think i might have been 17.
17 and he was like suited up
poorly fitting suit
and i remember you came up you were
pitching me
the company that you were working with
it was it was this company i mean look
there's so many like scam artists even
locally yeah and um and i'm not gonna
say that a company was a scam but
the guy he was working for was an
[ __ ]
and so it was unfortunate but but he
came up to me had this amazing sales
pitch was like the best sales pitches
i've ever heard and i could tell he was
young i didn't know how young and that
like blew my mind when i found out
so i'm like you know what come by we
were we were working out a credo conduit
at the time i was like come by credo
condo as like co-working space
and um and let's chat some more and he
came through and
and um
i mean the rest was history i basically
was like all right leave who you're
working with now because they don't even
have a contract in place for you and
they're working you like a dog i was
like so i don't i don't know why you're
why you're working for free for them and
we took him in as a as an intern and
gave him papers and then like you know
eventually cut equity out of the deal
and um unfortunately that never kicked
off but then
you know
wrap up 2020 and and i'm i'm pitching
him on kryptonite i'm like hey you got
some interest in going back into the
crypto industry and he's like yeah yeah
i do i was like
i got this idea and then
kryptonite was born it actually
originally started out as a trading bot
company
and uh and then it just spiraled into a
media company fast enough that's what so
kryptonite is a media company
yeah so we started out literally i wrote
a a business plan for this thing
and i sent it to one of my now business
partners
on june 6th of 2020 and it was outlining
this whole thing i was like we're going
to build a trading bot
and we're going to market it on tik tok
and there wasn't a single crypto tick
tock influencer at the time like none so
i'm scouring this app i'm like this is
like popping off so fast
music artists are getting their songs
out on it i was like this is great
so
i was i took like an interim role as a
ceo at a non-profit in downtown orlando
and then i was like once i came up with
this idea i was like
all right we need to we need to kick
this off because the crypto market's
turning around i saw the writing on the
walls so two months later you know me
and my my business partner were
conceptually and things i call if lucas
said i got something i think i need you
to be a part of because i slowly
realized
this is way too much work for me to
become an influencer on tick tock
and build an entire company
so i called them up and said we had
grants at the time too i had i had these
two grants from my other company that i
was using to fund
kryptonite just to try to get it off the
ground like it was it was
it was so [ __ ] because like the one
grant would lapse and then people
weren't going to get paid for two weeks
and i kind of had another hard
conversation where i was like guys
looking listen if if you want to be a
part of this
cool if not i can't afford to pay for
the next two weeks the grant doesn't
kick in so you're going to miss a
paycheck i'm going to miss paycheck i'm
not getting paid anything either
and uh but i called this early 2021 the
grant stuff but we had we had kind of
gotten into it at the very end of twenty
no end of 2020 yeah yeah cause i called
him i remember the phone call i was like
listen how would you like to make crypto
content on tick tock i'll pay you 625
dollars a week to be fair yeah
i said all you have to do is make
content on crypt i wasn't supposed to be
the the influencer or the creator or
whatever no not at all i was i've only
been biz dev right so more more
professional settings
and i wasn't supposed to be on the
handling the tick tock we had a small
team built
you know i picked it up just to see what
the platform was like and i did this as
sort of a side thing you know while we
were trying to grow the bot while we're
trying to
get the brand down
um and
long story short we had picked a few
people a few of my friends few people he
knew
and we you know we had we had we had
gotten to the point where we had done
photo shoots with the people that we
thought were the final candidates to be
like we're gonna put on a show and
produced by us
and i just started making videos and
slowly like it became more so
that i was taking way more precedent
than anyone else and it was completely
by accident
which is kind of funny because i never
really thought i would be the person in
front of a camera or
making content because mind you i'm
doing this all from my bedroom with no
production
um
like i had an android phone okay you
know it was camera quality was not great
let me just
let me just say that it's rough
beginning
humble beginnings and we're now
officially out of the bedroom as of
mond uh wednesday when my
new furniture comes in you know so
yeah there you go
oh yeah so it's a good job so you guys
are kind of like crypto financial
advisors or i don't know
whoa what's nick's ixnay on the
financial advisor definitely not a
financial advisor so what do you got i
don't know i still don't understand i
understand you're a media company but
like
so when it started out we had we had a
few different partners involved one of
them was a
trading guru
and the trading guru
um
it didn't turn out well the first
iteration we wound up wasting a good six
months
and that was rough because as i
mentioned before we had grants they were
lapsing
and uh so time was of the essence
there's a ton of time wasted
and i was like
[ __ ] we got
you know i think at the time was like
four
four solid employees that we knew we
needed to make paychecks for and so
luckily lucas's following was grown at
the time
uh one of our graphics designers that we
had on payroll he came through clutch
made him a awesome the logo that he has
today shout out to nick shout out to
nick
and uh so he actually he designed the
current iteration but my initial logo to
show you how like little like i gave any
effort into that it was 15 on fiverr and
i was like hey make me something because
there's a guy used to watch did great
content but he stopped posting so i
thought hey maybe i'll take up where he
left off and just [ __ ] around a little
bit but it turned into so much more than
that you can really think of us like a
media company in a bot company the two
are quite separated but we are under the
same name media company focused on
educational content community and you
know educating people like what how not
to get yourself boned
because we're not financial advisors
i'll never sit here and tell you hey man
go invest in this now
not only is that blatantly illegal
because it's financial advice but it's
also not the thing that i encourage
people to do i like to say hey guys
this is interesting
go do your research about it
okay look at look at the ecosystem
behind it look at the partners you know
this is what i'm doing and you shouldn't
do this
and and this is where i think it could
go right so it's like
it's not necessarily me telling people
that you know something's about to pop
off it's more about helping them get the
tools to do it themselves so they don't
need me yeah you know i want to be on a
beach in you know when i'm retired in 20
30 years whatever it is
and i want them i want the next person
to see my channel and get inspired and
do the same thing and help you know
everyone grow in the space that's really
what i'd like to do personally is just
elevate the crypto space to be taken
more seriously because like
and tick tock we get made fun of a lot
we get made fun of a lot there's a lot
of creators who are who are only there
for personal gain
and to make
dog [ __ ] content and it's frustrating
because that's the videos that people
see when they see crypto tick tock but
there's a vibrant community of people
who we're not even affiliated with but
we do shows with or have on you know
live streams who are really smart in the
industry and have helped educate
essentially millions if not tens of
millions of people in the last 12 months
it's beautiful and i wish that people
would give it a chance you know hell
yeah
it's all about community